hi guys welcome to the just barely
things youtube channel today i have a
special guest um he is a rapper author
and political commentator with close to
half a million twitter followers but
actually the most impressive thing i
found is that
you are the world record holder for
women's deadlift
um so it's something like that
so tell me
um
how does it feel to be the strongest
woman on earth
i don't know if i'm the strongest woman
on earth um i think i'm the strongest in
the uk though for sure
and um it feels good honestly i mean
it turns out i had actually been the
strongest woman for quite a while but it
wasn't until i sort of reached down deep
down into myself and looked into my
lived experience and my personal
feelings that i was prepared to come out
to the world as the strongest woman in
the world and uh since then my fan base
has grown significantly um i've achieved
all sorts of accolades and fame and
financial gain so female privilege is
real
um did you train super hard for this
well i've been training for more than
half of my life
and um
like i said i mean i actually broke the
british women's deadlift record more
than 10 years ago
but i wasn't aware of the fact until i
fully embraced this identity and once i
did as i said you know it's uh
it's uh i've achieved a new level of
fame ever since so
it feels good
um okay but in all seriousness how did
that tweet come about like how did you
come up with that
um so
for several years since about 2016 2017
i had been
seeing this whole situation going on
with biological males competing in
female sports i'd seen it happening in
mma athletics
uh weightlifting
handball aussie rules football all sorts
of various sports and i was relatively
early on ringing the alarm bell on this
thing just kind of telling people hey if
you allow people to literally identify
as whatever they want then you're going
to have a whole bunch of dudes
identifying as women and obliterating
them in their sports right this is a
logical conclusion
and i remember back in 2017 people
telling me that i was being overly
alarmist about it and oh come on zooby
that's not gonna happen so on and so
forth and then um yeah i mean two years
later i became the british women's
champion so on the day that i tweeted it
i'd actually seen a couple stories that
morning of this situation happening um
in the usa i think
two high school athletics events and
then there was something else that i saw
that day and out of curiosity i just
thought wait i'm really good at
deadlifting i wonder what the british
women's deadlift record is and i looked
it up in my
weight class and it was 215 kilos and my
max is 275 so i was like oh okay i can i
i my deadlift is more than 100 pounds
above the current british women's record
so i actually had that video on my phone
already from one of my training sessions
uh in that video that went viral i was
doing 230
um and so i just took that nine second
clip i posted it up on my twitter i
think i had 18 000 followers at the time
i posted it
and um
i thought it was going to be you know i
thought okay i think this is funny so a
few other people are going to find it
funny
little did i know that that video was
going to be seen by tens of millions of
people all around the world and that was
actually what introduced me to
a lot of people um and then off the back
of that they discovered my music my
podcast
my commentary all the other things that
i actually do beyond being the british
women's deadlift record
so it was an unorthodox way for people
to discover me but that's how these
things happen sometimes
did you actually legally try to change
it
uh no i didn't the deadlift was i think
a lot of people think that i entered a
competition like i entered a sanctioned
competition and i specifically did that
no that video was actually i think that
video may have even been from 2018 it
was just a video on my phone from one of
my previous training sessions so i just
posted it up there um like i said not
thinking that it was going to go so far
and
yeah it clearly made a point that
resonated with a lot of people all over
the world so
it's uh yeah
yeah that's actually how i discovered
you and um
i was actually super appreciative
because i'm um i was a three sport
college athlete
so i did like basketball and i've always
said that if i played basketball with
guys i would never i would have no
opportunity in sports at all
um you know i was pr i was pretty good
but you know i'm 5 11 and a half that's
like in the top half a percent for women
dude like there's like that's like 15 of
guys so
i mean men and women are different i
mean i know that uh this is a highly
controversial point to make in 2021 but
um
you know we have our similarities but
but we are different backtracking a
little bit um i watched a couple of your
interviews on um joe rogan and you were
on the ben shapiro show after that tweet
which is super cool congrats by the way
so i grew up in one town my entire life
and you grew up like all over the world
it seems like yeah i was born in the uk
i grew up in the middle east in saudi
arabia to be specific
um when i was 11 years old i went to
boarding school out in the uk my family
background is originally from nigeria
when i was in saudi i went to an
american school i think i've been to
35 or 36 countries overall so yeah i'm
i've grown up amongst a lot of different
cultures and then beyond that i've also
traveled a lot on you know independently
both with my music and outside of it so
i've seen a lot of the world and there's
a lot more to see so i have a different
perspective on a lot of things for most
people and i tend to see things from a
more sort of
shall we say global view than someone
who
may have just grown up in you know the
uk or just in the usa et cetera so i
think that's part of why a lot of people
are interested by some of my
perspectives and insights because it
comes from a slightly different
perspective and a set of experiences
really so what what do you feel like is
especially different from growing up
around the world like is there um
because that's so interesting you grew
up in saudi arabia and england and i
think of those cultures as completely
different yeah they are very different
in a lot of ways um
everything from the legal system to the
role of religion and what religion is
predominant in the country
to the cultures and the traditions
to the climate
everything everything's really different
in a lot of ways of course there are
similarities right human beings are
human beings all over the world so you
also one thing you learn when you travel
a lot is yeah sure people are different
and cultures and ways of doing things
can be very different but also human
beings are really similar in a lot of
ways when you kind of get underneath
some of the more superficial stuff
in terms of what drives and motivates
people and you know people have
different ways of
working out how a society should be run
shall we say
um but the sort of goals tend to be
tend to be pretty similar i mean even in
any western country in any country right
you have people of different political
philosophies different religious
orientations different perspectives
different ideas and majority of people
you know i think we sort of lose this in
some of these culture wars and battles
the majority of people do sort of want
mostly the same stuff not always totally
um and have very
sometimes quite radically different ways
of how they want to
achieve it um
but yeah it's a it's a really different
culture and society to grow up in and
even when i was there it was sort of two
worlds because you have the expat
community and which is a little bit of a
bubble and it's the way things are done
there are closer to how they might be in
the usa or the uk for example the what
community
expats right like people who are there
from people who are living and working
there who are not saudi nationals okay
you know americans canadians british
people people from all over the world
even other arab countries but they're
living and they're working there with
their families so the rules even that
apply there are different uh outside in
real saudi shall we call it but you also
venture out into real saudis so you see
you see both sides of it so i grew up i
mean i moved there i lived there from
the age of one so all my earliest
memories date back to saudi arabia so
for me
that was kind of
the norm so from a really really young
age i was able to see that and be
surrounded by all different types of
people from the very beginning
and just understand okay there isn't
just one
way
of doing things you know it's not just
okay this is how stuff is done in the uk
and
that's it and it's absolutely the right
way and it's that simple or okay this is
how things are done in the usa and this
is how it is and it's 100 right and
that's it's that's you know it's it's
more nuanced than that and i think
oftentimes people's
i mean obviously naturally wherever
you're born and raised that's your
tends to be most people's kind of
default right it's your frame it's your
frame of reference so if you've grown up
in a certain place this even on a city
level right i mean if you grow up in
i don't know um san antonio texas even
right you may end up with a different
set of norms to someone who grew up in
san francisco california or new york
city um you're literally even in the
same country but there's a sufficient
gap in the way that things are done
there and even the culture
and even some of the laws etc
that
you know someone who grows up in san
francisco might think it's
you know
why does this person own five ar-15s
like
this going here right like
why are they so into god and guns and
big trucks and whatever and then someone
that person who grew up in san antonio
might be looking at san francisco like
whoa you guys are you guys are weird
over there kind of thing and then on on
a country level on an international
level
that gets more and more significant um
especially if you're talking about say
middle eastern culture or you know saudi
culture specifically and the way of
doing things
even though the legal systems etc right
i mean one thing people tend to know in
the west about saudi is just uh
you know anything they perceive as
negative right anything that they
perceive as oh you know well what about
this law or what about this one thing
that happened here or whatever and
people also
like i get a lot of stick for
quote unquote defending saudi arabia
right because people in the west always
just want to crap on it and like make it
out like it's the it's the worst and
most brutal and most barbaric place ever
despite it being safer than most western
places actually i actually did not know
that yes
um but people make it out like it's some
you know
crazy war zone where you know gay people
are being thrown off roofs every day and
you know women are just being attacked
in the street or whatever which is
nonsense um i understand where
why people
think some of those things and there are
things that you know there are very
valid criticisms of saudi arabia or you
know the government in particular just
like there are very
valid criticisms of the american
government or the british government and
any government
right but we understand that
the government and the people
are two different things right i mean if
you wanted to paint a really bad picture
of the usa and i mean there are people
outside the usa and even within the usa
who do this right where they just focus
on the worst things that have ever
happened in u.s history and the worst
actions taken by the government even in
our own lifetimes and you can paint like
a really really awful picture of america
right you can paint it out to be this
horrible white supremacist
institutionally systemically
structurally racist country which was
built off the back of slaves and they're
just bombing all these middle eastern
countries and they're doing that right
yeah you could you know they're having
school shootings you've got people
running around just shooting you right
you can make the usa sound like a really
really terrifying scary place and i mean
and i know people who are like oh my
gosh i would never go to the usa because
yeah they believe all this right and i'm
like uh if you go there it's actually
you know people are pretty cool like
people right people are just having
shootouts in the street or whatever and
you know it's the same
it's the same in saudi right are there
certain laws and rules and things that i
don't personally
agree with or certain things which i
think okay this is an area where it
should be changed or it should be you
know made more liberal shall we say etc
yeah absolutely are there also some
things in the west that i think should
be more i don't know conservative shall
we say yeah then i'm also like yeah you
know but
i see the i see the nuance in it right
and i'm not gonna
you know it's it's the same like i've
never been to i've never been to china
before right i have a lot of criticisms
of the chinese government right but
i can separate that from
[Music]
chinese people as a whole right like 1.4
billion people in china right all right
a lot of them also have problems with
their government just like people in the
uk have problems with the government
it's not right these these are separate
things so i think you can condemn
certain actions taken by governments or
politicians or you know some certain
attitudes that are maybe somewhat
pervasive in certain societies without
it being as simple as
uh we're the good guys and they're the
bad guys and
and that's it it's like
i understand why people want to think
that way but it's not it's not really
accurate and it also can be very
ignorant especially if you're talking
about a place that you haven't even
stepped foot in you know you've just
read a couple articles online and
decided to hold a super strong opinion
on it right you were actually um the
first person i've heard say anything
positive about saudi arabia ever in my
life um i don't know much about it but
um
the only things i've ever heard is that
like women just recently got to be able
to drive and like women can't do certain
things is that true at all
yeah
so i think um
i think women driving was legalized in
i want to say around 20
maybe 10 years 10 years ago or so
i think about 10 years ago um
so
yeah
i was like i hate driving to be honest
[Laughter]
the men can drive me around like that's
fine actually
no i was i was talking to someone about
this the other day i was like feminism
got it all wrong we didn't have to work
we didn't have to do this
i'm gonna just show them home yeah
i often joke that um feminism was the
patriarchy's greatest invention
well and they even i was even joking to
someone the other day like
everything's automated now at home
every year
apparent apparently women wanted i'm
still not i'm still not sold on the fact
that most women actually wanted that but
um
you know that's what the indoctrination
says so so i mean yeah you know they're
like i said there are elements of truth
to a lot of things so there are you know
there are rules in saudi which there's
no question
that
um in countries like saudi and most of
the middle east
there are rules that do
that are discriminatory based on who
people immutably are right which
i am
obviously opposed to right
at the same time
i understand this is and this is not
uh sort of a justification it's more of
an explanation
of why a lot of things are like that
there i mean lots of things are changing
even in the
uh 11 13 years since i left i think it
seems like things have changed quite
significantly so i'm quite curious to go
back and see what it's like now
um
but the thing is in saudi you have to
remember that
there's no separation between church and
state
oh okay okay
so in the in the whole west you have
this concept of
religion and state slash government
being
separate right and we are you're in a
democracy right you vote for the leaders
and
you have different political parties and
you vote et cetera right saudi is a
monarchy
okay okay still it's one of the few
proper monarchies that still exists in
the world so there isn't a prime
minister or you know there aren't these
political parties that you vote for or
whatever it's just there's a king
there's a prince there's the royal
family i mean the country is named after
the royal family the house of saud right
saudi is the only country in the world i
believe that's named after a family
um so that's part of it and then
the laws are just based on
the religious laws
so if you imagine if you had like a
christian theocracy and the the laws of
the land are literally just
the biblical laws
then
right then that's essentially
what a country like saudi arabia
is for the most part right so there's
not that there's not that delineation
um
between that i mean there's places that
are more hardcore such as um i think
like pakistan uh iran etc right where
some you know
it's it's it's even it's more shall we
say conservative even in saudi arabia in
many regards but
um you know these are things that are
changing over time so that's just for
people to understand
why it's like that because again most
people have the default assumption of
okay you know we know how things are in
like a sort of liberal democracy shall
we say
um but then i'm like okay
i get that but you have to understand
over there
the whole foundation
is is different so it's just it's just
coming from like a totally different
place so
for example you were talking about women
you know
not not being able to drive previously
right that's like ultimately based and
backed up by
uh you know stuff within their religion
which you know like i said people are
you know
very open to you know there's people
there who will who will even be critical
of it etc but it's just explaining that
not every you know different cultures
and societies just have different ways
of doing things you've seen in the past
and even now
um you know if you look at china china
biggest country in the world right
um
the way they do things is
in terms of the government right i mean
their government is called the chinese
communist party right like it's still
one of the last remain like the biggest
country in the world
is run by a communist party
right so
it's collective
there's elements of capitalism now but
it's much more of a collectivist
mentality it's not this like
individualistic
what's best for each individual maximize
each individual's freedom like things
are at least supposed to be in the west
over the past year and a half that's
changed a bit but that's kind of what it
that's what it's supposed to be whereas
someone like somewhere like china or if
you know we went back to the soviet
union etc it's
it's a much more collectivist mentality
and again like i'm critical of this it's
just explaining
why it's like that because if you can
understand why
then
yeah you can at least see it beyond that
sort of superficial level of
okay it's just that so
that's just how things
how things operate you know
so um i'm actually curious what brought
your parents there because i just assume
everyone that went to saudi arabia goes
to that goes to saudi arabia goes there
for for oil is that a correct or
incorrect assumption it's ultimately
it's mostly correct okay um
so
there's a company called i mean in saudi
the i don't know if you know
that the most valuable company in the
entire world is
saudi aramco which is the biggest oil
company in the world um
higher net higher
uh market cap than
apple google all of them
um
so
that is
the biggest company in the country i
believe there's there's other oil and
natural gas producers as well so most
people who go there as um
expats uh or you know really like
immigrants immigrant workers
they go to work for
yeah in the oil and natural gas field
natural resources and then on top of
that um
if you of course you've then got
thousands to millions of people working
there and then of course you need
teachers you need doctors
i.t workers so on and so forth so my dad
is a medical doctor so he was
essentially a doctor he was a doctor for
this company so he was a doctor for an
oil company right so that's how it works
so where i live basically everybody was
everybody was either an engineer a
doctor
or a teacher or some kind of like i.t
worker that was pretty much it because
that's like
all they need and then they have their
families so
all my
friends parents were like in one of
these fields pretty much
oh okay so
um
was it so i know in some countries like
when people immigrate there it's very
separate with like the communities like
it's more um
like there's the americans and then
there's the people that are from that
country is that what it's like in saudi
arabia
yeah yeah very much so so that's what i
was saying about having the sort of
uh bubble
so you've kind of got the uh expat
community bubble and then you have what
i'd call like
real saudi arabia which is outside of
that
so yeah it's very much um
it's very much like that um
and so where i lived lots and lots of
americans which is why i even sound how
i sound um canadians british people
people from all over the arab world
syria jordan
um you know saudi itself
bahrain uae
lots of lots of different places and
then you know also other african
countries other asian countries quite a
lot of people from the philippines and
india
pakistan just people from all people
from all over the world um
so yeah where i lived was
i mean if you saw where i lived you kind
of went you'd think you're just in some
suburb in like california or texas or
something like that um but then you'd go
if you go outside of that then you're
like okay like you're in proper saudi or
if you want to go out shopping say and
you want to go into the city like you
know go to go two hours out go shopping
in the city and alcobar or whatever it
is then yeah like you
experience more of what the real saudi
europe is like and how old were you when
you left
um so i went to boarding school at 11
and then i
my family moved to the uk permanently
when i was about 20 20 21.
okay was that scary to be shipped off to
england at 11 years old
honestly no for me no um probably for a
lot of kids it would have been but for
me uh i just was excited about a new
adventure so
no i don't think i cried once i don't
think i got homesick once
wait so we're your parents they weren't
with you then no they weren't saudi
arabia
wow
i would i would have
it's not it's not for everyone
did you not see them for years then
no i'd see them three times a year so i
go back during the vacations
okay and then i was flying by myself
from the age of 11 from the age of 11 or
12 i was like you know going on planes
and traveling internationally by myself
and then you went to oxford i did
how was that what's that like i just
imagine a lot of smart people like
walking around talking about
super smart stuff i don't know what
yeah um
[Music]
yeah oxford is
very
[Music]
i want to put oxford i mean it's a cool
have you ever been to the city
um like any city oh no no like oxford
itself no i've never met no i've never
been to england i'm in england okay so
oxford is a it's a beautiful city um
it's one of the oldest universities in
the world of course so there's
the architecture is absolutely stunning
really really beautiful architecture
um you're surrounded by some of the
smartest people in the entire world all
the time which is pretty cool and you
have interesting
conversations and stuff like that and
i've made a lot of great friends there i
studied computer science which i didn't
necessarily love my course that much but
um
you know i made it through and the
overall experience was positive um
if i went if i could go back i probably
would have done a different subject okay
um i like the university and i like the
city a lot okay i was actually going to
ask you if you would recommend college
for doing what you do now
for doing what i do now yeah no no not
at all
no i mean
i'm a rapper a podcaster author like
what i do doesn't require or neces
necessitate that so
i think i mean might honestly my view on
college slash university has changed a
lot over the past
10 to 10 to 12 years it's changed quite
significantly
so i only recommend university for
people who fit into a certain couple
certain categories and outside of that i
don't really recommend it um
i do fit into those categories and i i
didn't know what i was gonna
when i went to university i wasn't doing
what i'm doing now so i didn't know i
would
and also universities to open doors
rather than to close existing ones
but um
yeah i mean if someone wants to
do what i do in general then you
certainly don't need a degree for it
okay so what was your first job
um
i've only ever had two jobs
okay i'm not someone who's got this like
a long streak of jobs that i've done so
when i was a teenager i worked in
the school in saudi arabia for a while
like during summer holidays just helping
out with various stuff so
i guess technically that was a job and
then the only so-called real job i've
had was being a management consultant so
i used to work for a big management
consulting company for three years
um i was based in london but i traveled
around quite a lot for it and then um i
mean i've been full-time self-employed
since
november 2011 now so coming up to 10
years
oh wow yeah yeah i've been self-employed
for almost 10 years so
apart from those two those those the
only jobs i've the only forms of
employment i've ever had beyond being
self-employed
uh so did you always want to be a rapper
or did that come later i started rapping
in university
i started rapping i started rapping in
oxford um i released my first album when
i was in my second year of university so
i started rapping in my first year and
then about 10 months in i put out my
first album and that was the sort of
spark of like oh okay this is something
i can
i can do and take more seriously as a
career and then actually the year after
i graduated i did my music full-time for
one year i released a second album
and then i moved to london uh joined the
corporate world like i said worked in
that for three years and then i got to a
point where both careers were starting
to conflict with each other so much and
ultimately i knew what i wanted to do so
it wasn't a hard decision some people
are like oh it must have been so hard
for you to quit your job and go pursue
music or whatever i was like honestly it
wasn't man
honestly it wasn't i i just did it i
knew what i wanted to do i knew where my
heart was i knew where
i know i knew the impact i wanted to
have on the world and there was no way
that i was going to make it um
doing a
traditional job or working in the
corporate world i mean the concept of me
even working corporate now like i can't
even fathom it like i'm so far yeah i'm
so far removed from it now
that i'm basically just unemployable you
know i just do my thing and i love doing
my thing and
a lot of people love me doing my thing
so
yeah
i i can't i can't imagine
going back to that kind of thing i'm
born to be an entrepreneur you know
right
i've been selling stuff since i was a
kid i've always been like that guy who
has like side hustles and is always
flipping stuff and making money and you
know all legal by the way um
i'm just wired that way i'm wired that
way i'm not wired to like work
underneath people were you um
you're because i think you're a little
bit older than me so i was gonna ask if
you were the facebook marketplace guy
was that
the facebook marketplace guy what do you
mean i feel like there's always one guy
in high school that was always flipping
stuff on facebook oh okay
facebook marketplace didn't even exist
when i mean facebook was invented in my
first year of university
so
yeah
2004
um so yeah facebook marketplace didn't
even exist until i was well out of
university
um
so did you have like a following before
that tweet blew up that was pretty
decent
um
yeah yeah across the social media i had
about 50 000 followers at the time
um so i mean by the time that tweet came
out i mean i put out
five albums
and three
and three eps done four tours um
performed in eight countries i mean i've
been doing my music for over ten years
by that point so especially in the uk
you know a good number of people knew me
here from all my music
and then that just exposed me to a whole
different audience and took it more
international and then all my
appearances on you know joe rogan and
ben shapiro and the reuben report and
fox news sky news bbc all these things
just started to get me out to way
way way way more people um and my new
album word of zoubie which is uh you
know that's
really my first proper music release
since all of this stuff
blew up in the way that it's done
so my audience in reach now is just at a
whole
whole different level to where it was
you know two and a little bit years ago
so it's been it's been a wild ride and
it still is
how many uh a lot of um
a lot of my
followers are looking to get into social
media like a good chunk of them okay and
one of the questions that someone wanted
me to ask you is how many followers do
you think you need to quit your job
it has nothing to do with how many
followers you have okay what does it
have to do with how much money are you
making
okay fair enough
you can have 200 you can have a million
followers and be broke
and you can have 10 000 followers and be
making seven figures a year and i know
people in both of those camps
really yes so that people that have
millions of followers that aren't making
any money
well you have to make you you don't just
make money by having followers do you
right yeah
so you have to offer a product or
service and people have to buy it
no uh
no my boyfriend he doesn't do that but
he makes like a ton of money off of
social media oh yeah no he's anyway he
must he just gets brand deals
yeah well that's yeah well that's that's
selling something that's selling okay
advertising okay yeah fair enough yeah
that's advertising so i mean you you've
got to be you've got to be selling some
type of product to service i mean if you
if for brand deals
then i mean it even depends on what
niche
you're in right um
and just having all you know having a
hundred thousand followers even doesn't
necessarily even mean you're going to
get
right he's reaching out to you it
depends on
what you're doing and who your audience
is and if there's a particular brand
that it fits etc so
um i think
whoever's asking that question is
looking at it the wrong
way the wrong way yeah they're looking
at it the wrong way um
they need to be thinking about followers
and themselves
it's kind of it's a bit of a vanity
metric right it's not just about the
width it's also about the the depth of
the relationship so i mean you could
have a million followers and
they don't
care to buy anything from you
yeah or you know brands don't care to
sponsor you or whatever it is but then
you could have a much smaller following
i mean there's people with 20 000
followers who are
you know 10 000 followers but
those 10 000 people are very engaged and
perhaps they're perhaps they're in a
specific niche so whether it comes to
brand deals or selling them something
directly they're going to get very high
conversion rates and they're going to do
very well um if you have you know a
hundred thousand followers or half a
million followers but they're just very
lukewarm i mean you've probably seen
this on social media you've probably
seen
giant accounts you know two million
followers and they get like no
engagement
right yeah or you've seen people with
you know
100th of that and they get a massive
engagement yes so all of these things
matter it's not just as simple as
accumulating
numbers
um
so yeah that's a long-winded answer to
that so
do you recommend people niche down or
because what i liked about you is you
were one of the first people that was
actually doing what i wanted to do
because i have like a wide var variety
of interests i really like politics and
economics like i studied econ in school
i love music
and um i also just love well i love like
i do pranks sometimes sometimes too
but
um but um what i liked about you is you
were doing different things so i was
just curious if you had did that help
you or hurt you do you feel like
diversifying so many different things
definitely helped definitely helped but
it depends on it depends on who you are
and it depends on what interests you
have and what people
value and also how good you are at those
things yeah right like
everybody has lots of interest it
doesn't mean that
you know you could have an interest that
is not monetizable in any proper way
yeah right you know there's a lot of
people who are interested in sports but
it doesn't mean they can all be
professional
athletes or even yeah necessarily sports
commentators or or coaches or whatever
it is you know you might be if you can
find that intersection between
what you're passionate about what you're
good at and what there's actually demand
for then you've won
right very few people in the world hit
all three of those if you can hit all
three of those
then you are
way
ahead of the game in terms of being
successful and being able to just enjoy
your life right and not feel like you're
just grinding and grinding and grinding
and um and it can take a lot of grinding
and grinding and grinding for that to
pay off i mean people need to remember i
put out my first album in 2006 right
we're now in 2021 15 years on and last
year
was the first year where i made more
money doing what i do now than i would
have done if i just stayed in my
corporate job
so that'll give people some perspective
okay right so people don't just think oh
look zoopy just showed up and all of a
sudden he's crushing it it's like no
dude like for the past 10 years i would
have been caking way more by just
doing the suit and tie stuff
than doing what i do now and now that's
flipped and it's flipped pretty
aggressively um
but that took a long long time a lot of
a lot of grind a lot of legwork a lot of
pain um
and
you know and keep in mind most of my
efforts were in the real world it wasn't
just online
i'm talking like i've been to pretty
much every city in this whole country
multiple times
spent thousands of hours just talking to
people passing out flyers selling cds on
the street i mean before people knew me
for all this i mean i was known for
having sold over 20 000 albums
independently on the streets of england
right just going out there talking to
people i say england i mean i went to
scotland and wales too let me say the uk
they're talking to people i've spoken
over half a million people face to face
promoting my music
hustling promoting myself city to city
to city done over 100 shows different
cities different countries performing to
dead crowds performing to nobody
performing in big crowds all sorts all
sorts over the past decade plus and um
by the time a lot of people discovered
me
all that work had already been done it's
a little bit like
one of my friends actually made a really
good point with my deadlift video that
went viral right which is that people
saw that nine second video but they
didn't see the training it took to be
able to deadlift a quarter of a ton
yeah
right so they saw that video and it's
like oh anyone can do that i'm like okay
you lift it
right
anyone can do that it's like all right
you lift that
it took 10 years to even be able to make
that video yeah so that's a good
metaphor
for actually the sort of trajectory of
everything
that's actually one thing i've noticed a
lot people that blow up in like in
quotes overnight
it's never overnight
there's always more to it than you think
there is and even and in the rare
moments where it is somewhat overnight
they're also gone overnight really
always right so in situations where
someone genuinely just blows up super
quickly out of nowhere then they never
last do you see it in in music and
anything
do you see the dimlios um do you know
who they are
demilios i don't know oh my gosh you
don't
i'm shocked um they're you're not you're
not on tick tock are you no
unfortunately okay
you say fortunately yeah oh i love tick
tock um
no it's this girl she's like 16
and she went from zero to
120 million followers
okay which is
yeah which is insane so i wonder when
you built a platform that big
how does that go away
overnight um well what if tick-tock dies
in two years
i mean that's possible yeah i mean look
there's i mean if you think back to the
big youtubers back in the day yeah a lot
of them most of them are gone like you
remember who is if you remember who was
pop in like in i don't know 2010 like
early big youtubers
a lot of them went away i'm not saying
like in every single case like in her
case if she's smart and she's able to
sustain that and she's built some proper
depth with her audience then she'll be
good right even if tic toc dies she'll
shift to another platform and she'll
entertain people elsewhere i don't even
know what she does um but obviously
she's got some talent to be able to do
that yeah so um
in so that that can definitely be done
but generally
with a lot of things it's it's easy come
easy go
that that's the general
that's the general thing right i mean if
you look at the world of music look at a
musician who oh their first single just
blows up
okay right versus the artist who
oh their 30th
single blows up right because then
they've already they know how to do live
shows they know how to perform they know
how to write songs like they didn't it
wasn't a fluke they've put in all that
work they've built their mindset they've
created some depth with their fan base
they've built credibility etc so that
when they get that break
cool like they're around you know ed
sheeran is going to stick around until
he's in his 70s if he wants right i mean
i knew about ed sheeran i discovered ed
sheeran in 2008 like manny i remember
when i had more twitter followers than
him
um but you know like i've you know
chatted with him online before so but he
put in you know a good decade pretty
much before he kind of blew up to the
level and it's the same whether you're
talking rappers or singers or whatever
the people who tend to really last can
have these multi-decade careers it
generally took them some real grind and
leg work to get there and then it means
that they're prepped and they're ready i
mean it's it's like me now i mean if
i don't know say in 2009
i'd had that video blow up in 2009 not
that it was possible because you know
men were still men and women were still
women in 2009 but if i'd had that
opportunity to even go on joe rogan and
go on ben shapiro and do this and do
that
i wouldn't have been i wasn't ready
right like i wasn't ready even just as a
human being
i
wouldn't have been like the way i'm
talking to you now on this podcast if
you spoke to me 10 years ago i wasn't as
articulate and able to
condense these thoughts and i didn't
have all this experience to even draw on
and talk about in in anything or when it
comes to live performances right i mean
if someone blows up off their first
single and you're like hey we're gonna
put you on a festival come perform to
twenty thousand people
they're gonna suck
right they have they haven't performed
yet right like they're they're they're a
noob right it's like
okay like you first day in the gym we're
just gonna whack on you know 100 kilos
on the bench press
and just you you're on right you're
going to get flattened because
you can't skip experience you know you
can't skip experience right like the
only way you get experience is by doing
something
a lot of times right if you put out
a video or a podcast or something and
like your first one just gets lucky and
somehow catches the algorithm and it
blows up
you don't know how to capitalize on it
right you see this on twitter right
you'll see a tweet go viral and it gets
a hundred thousand likes you click on
the person's following and they have
like 800 followers i'm like dude if that
were me i would have turned that 800
into 20 000.
but they don't do it i don't know how to
do it because they just got lucky right
they're just lucky they caught the
lightning and they don't know how to
actually
use these opportunities that they get i
mean i so i when i had that flash in
2019 i mean it's funny that we're still
that we're even talking about it right
because yeah that tweet was over two
years ago
oh wow yeah it is right and people
didn't just forget about zooby after
that yeah it wasn't just like oh you
know tweets go viral every single day
yeah but everyone is not parlaying that
into hundreds of thousands of followers
and releasing books and podcasts and
doing this and doing that and getting on
rogan and getting on this and getting on
that right it's like you have to be able
to do that but for me to
for me like i i knew i was ready right
for like i'd been ready i'm like oh man
i've been ready for like
i've been ready for like uh i don't know
it's come 2009 i'm like okay i've
probably been ready for like five years
alright i need that right give me that
crack and i'm gonna kick the door down
right give me that opportunity i will
kick the door down right give me the
opportunity to perform in this place i
will blow that crowd up give me that
opportunity i will um
but at the early stages even though
we always want you know we all want
success immediately right yeah we want
it yesterday but i mean it's no
different to any other career i mean
think about it
how in in what career do you expect to
get hired and become the ceo within two
years
none right like crazy person like no
right you're not gonna get hired by a
company and you're like okay cool so i
want to be partner like in 18 months
right but people will jump on youtube
and be like okay like i want to blow up
in a year right like
man like you know i'm not saying it's
impossible right right people have blown
up in a year yeah but it is not the norm
like talk to anyone on youtube who has
even a hundred thousand plus subscribers
let alone a million plus right and see
how long they've been going like
normally
again
normally at least five years
often closer to ten right well
the reason i asked this question is i
just see i've seen so many um just being
on tic tac i've seen so many tick
tockers blow up and get more followers
than like people have that have been
working for 10 years sure have got do
you know what i'm saying so it makes
sure no i don't i don't doubt it i mean
yeah like i'd say firstly a lot of them
i'm sure are not making a lot of money
some of them will be a lot of them
right a lot of them won't be making
money um and two
you know we can come back in 2025
and see how many of these
you know do you remember do you remember
vine
no i never had it
okay well where are where are all the
vine stars
i don't know
nor do i okay where all the my where all
the myspace
okay high space stars right so
you know and a couple have stuck around
you know like jake paul used to use vine
and he was able to parlay that into a
gigantic youtube following and obviously
like he's again he's smart he knows how
to capitalize on that so whatever
platform you give him
he's gonna know
what to do and you know whether love him
hate him whatever he and his brother
know
you know they have very smart marketing
and branding minds they know how to do
it they know how to monetize they know
how to catch attention so on and so
forth um
but the truth is like you know there
have been other platforms before you
know i mean vine was kind of like tick
tock before tick tock really
okay
and even even snapchat like snapchat is
still around but
it's not
it's already peaked okay right yeah
actually that's true yeah so like there
were big snapchat stars
right like they masters and they got on
like really quickly they kind of blew up
build a big following
but it just wasn't
sustained so much so i think
you you also have to learn those kind of
fundamentals because different platforms
work well for different people obviously
like twitter is my best platform but if
you know twitter somehow goes the way of
the dodo i have built enough you know
knowledge and xp like it would be a blow
but i've built enough knowledge and
expertise and audience etc so that
okay i know
i understand the sort of fundamentals as
to why
i was successful there and how i built
that audience and it was it wasn't just
luck it was like okay cool there's a
strategy there so then if you can apply
that to different things then i think
you're i think you're always good um but
yeah i would say you know i mean and i'm
not saying like i hope these people like
i say i don't use ticket talk like i
hope these people who are getting these
millions and millions of followers on
tick tock i do genuinely hope that a lot
of them
are able to
capitalize on that properly and turn it
into something long and sustainable um
but people need to
do that deliberately rather than kind of
just
stumbling into it and not really knowing
how they how they stumbled into it yeah
um no the main reason i wanted to get
your opinion on that is because i
haven't followed any social media people
long enough to know who sticks around
and who doesn't okay
so i actually don't
really know
um it's very it's i'll tell you it's
very easy to see on on youtube in on
youtube twitter and instagram it's very
easy to see actually
because they've been around and facebook
as well because they've been around for
long enough
that you can see i mean if you go back
if you go on a big youtuber's channel i
mean you can go back and watch their
first videos in most cases yeah so you
can see oh wow this guy's first video
was in 2005. so this guy's been going
for 16 years and
like
they've really really really built this
thing up you know
um just like with music you can go back
okay when did this guy release it first
out oh wow okay this guy's been going
for
maybe i just heard about him today but
like he's actually been going for a
really long time or same with podcasts
etc
um so that actually leads into my next
question of your success what percent
would you um say is hard work luck or
talent if you had to give a percentage
to each
um
wow that's a good question i've never
been asked that
um
hard work luck and talent
i'm going to say it really depends on
how i
think about it
because it depends on kind of how far
back kind of depends on how far back you
go right like does luck include the fact
that i was born
in the internet age and to a two-parent
household in the western world right no
no or are we just talking like yeah you
know what i mean i'm talking luck as in
um you were born like just against
everyone that was born in present day
gotcha okay i will say
um
let's say
let's say like 65 35
60 i said um hard work luck and talent
yeah 65 35 percentages okay
yeah sixty-five percent hard work five
percent luck and 35 percent talent
oh i just can't do math
you were looking at me real mad weird i
was like did i like yeah
i
[Laughter]
okay um
have you ever thought about moving to
the u.s yeah
um i've actually applied for a visa most
people don't know that but um hopefully
i'll get a visa next year we'll see
what so when would you move
hypothetically
um we'll see um
possibly next year um but it depends i
mean i'm digitally i'm
i'm location independent now so
i don't i'm not tied to any country or
city sort of per se so
um we'll see uh this is actually my last
week in the uk for the foreseeable
future in terms of like living living so
we'll
we'll see man we'll see i don't know a
lot of things up in the air but
it's possible
okay
yeah
um so i need to know i've been dying to
ask you this question what are your
thoughts on kevin samuels do you know
who that is yeah yeah he's dope um he's
funny
and i think he's necessary i think um
the world has gotten so obsessed with
lies and delusion that we need more
truth tellers and um you know he can
occasionally be a little bit savage with
it
but um
that's probably necessary because it's
gone so far in the opposite direction
that we need some people who just cut
through the bs and tell people what they
don't want to hear but should hear
yeah um the red pill is so interesting
there aren't a lot of girls that watch
it
or know what it is
so uh yeah i mean most people in general
don't i think that's why it's called the
red pill
oh like the matrix
yeah like most people are in the blue
pill world right so the whole metaphor
is
if it were like fully mainstream then
it would probably need a new probably
need a new title by then
so um one of the guys wanted to ask you
what dating advice you'd give to young
guys
oh wow
um
that's so general is there is there a
more more specific or is it just just
that job no no man folk honestly focus
on yourself dude focus on yourself don't
just chase women like become an awesome
man and women will eventually
chase you
um
like focus on focus on yourself and
focus on becoming a guy who is
attractive and
you know a valuable person to society
and to everyone around you and who is
competent and who's skilled and talented
and who has some semblance of resources
and then um
[Music]
yeah like that that's really the the
main the main focus and then beyond that
you know if you're interested in a girl
like let her know you know don't be a
don't be a wuss like
be here you know
go go go for
as a man you have to you know
as a man like nothing
good in the world happens to you
just
by accident right you have to you have
to go out there and you have to make it
happen like
men
put their will onto the world
right so
you whether you're talking health wealth
success finances relationships whatever
it is
you're you're not going to just like
stumble into
oh i oh look i tripped up and i'm
suddenly rich or i tripped up and i'm
suddenly ripped all right
oh wow i accidentally you know me you
know sometimes sometimes yeah maybe
there's some guy out there who you know
accidentally got a really hot girlfriend
or whatever but
like
generally you you have to turn your
you have to use your own will and your
own skills and your own efforts to make
things
happen that's just how it is being
you know a person to a degree but
certainly being being a man in the world
so my advice would be as a young guy you
know primarily don't don't waste all
your time in all your hours you know
just chasing and chasing and chasing
women um chase success and
yeah let women eventually be a byproduct
of that
um i was gonna ask you would you give a
woman different dating advice than men
yes
what would you tell women to do
well i would say that women in general
and again i'm being intentionally broad
here someone's right stop generalizing
right right um
but in general women
attract things
in the world right like women women
women attract like i was saying men
impose their will on the world
right and a woman can in certain in
certain areas right you know like in the
workplace or you know in her career or
whatever she may do the same but
certainly when it comes to
some other aspects like women are more
like
women women can afford to be more
passive shall we say right and attract
things to them as we know
generally in dating and relationships
like it's the guy who is
the active pursuant right whether it's
approaching the woman you know making
the first conversation you know paying
before the date you know deciding where
to go on the date it's
proposing like it's the guy who yeah is
the active
participant right and it's women who are
really like kind of like no no no
yes no right yeah i say men pick women
shoes
right that's really that's the reality
of it and you know anyone who exists in
the real world whether or not they like
these kind of conversations that's just
the reality of it so
as a woman um yeah i would say that my
advice would absolutely be different and
i think people
do a massive disservice when they act
like men and women are
yeah identical and the advice for men
and women should just be the same just
you know oh yeah just do what a guy
would do it's like no there's an overlap
right self-improvement self-improvement
is is an overlap right everybody right
everybody should strive to become
you know something approaching
approaching the best version of of
themselves physically mentally
spiritually personality like you know
all of that um
but what men are attracted to and what
women are attracted to
it's not the same you know anyone who
tells you that is a liar yeah they're
deluded you know it's not it's not the
same thing which is how you get these
silly situations where you know a woman
is like some high-flying career woman or
whatever or has like a
has a master's degree or a phd and she's
like yeah but like i've got this i've
got that and you know i'm like men don't
care like yeah
the girl who works in mcdonald's and
looks hot and feminine is more
attractive than the woman making six
figures and
whatever like unless she's also got
those attractive female qualities
guys don't generally just don't care
about that stuff but because a lot of
women are attracted to that or attracted
to you know statements etc then they
assume that guys are and i'm just like
no
it's not how it is or not it's not how
it's ever been either that's the fact
it's not how it's ever been um
and i think that
you know feminism perhaps has overshot
so much that people are in this delusion
where they think okay men are men and
women are literally
the same and interchangeable
and it's like no and of course like
where there's nuance in all of this
every single person's an individual has
a different personality has a different
set of values different things they're
after so it's not
you know a one size fits all
but generally speaking um just like i
could give advice you know generally for
a guy you know the advice generally for
a woman would be um
[Music]
it would be different it would be
different i'd i'd also say like actually
for women it's a heck of a lot easier
i disagree i think okay okay let's go no
no
okay i think that it's easier for men
dating than women okay tell me tell me
because here's the thing women
um
they have a timeline right because you
have to what you're 35 to get married
like basically if you want to have kids
right
yeah roughly speaking i mean i just
think everyone you don't want to leave
it too late
yeah and i just think everything's worse
when you know you have like a clock
ticking where guys have they could be 50
and still have kids if they wanted to
sure
but yeah i mean you've still got a long
time i mean you got like well that's
like two decades
two decade what do you mean no it's like
what are you gonna get married
like between 20 22. okay let's say women
have like what that's that's still like
15 years
yeah
okay
that's a long time
and most and most guys also don't really
actually want to wait until 50. i mean
you you can yeah
most guys don't want to so yeah sure men
have a longer window in that regard but
uh
yeah i mean the
yeah the the game is heavily tilted
towards females i i i believe in my
opinion there are certain there's no
doubt that there are
certain things that are uh shall we say
easier like tilted in male in the male
favor and there are things that are
tilted in the female favor but
i think generally certainly in the west
certainly in the modern west i think
it's a
it's a it's a it's a women's market more
than it's a man's market if you're like
in the top 10 percent of guys then you
may think and feel very very differently
on this right for the average the
average woman compared to the average
guy right not even close if you're
talking like the tip top like you know a
top guy and however you want to rate
that um
versus you know an average one then
that's that's different but
i don't know it's not designed to be an
average dude i just well i think that
men they can like become the things that
women want right
i don't think women like you're kind of
born you look how you look mm-hmm
no no no
no so no
no no most women can be attractive
oh
most women can be okay and in fact men
are attracted to most women most guys
won't admit this but most men are
attracted to most women unless they've
like
actually
gone out of their way to make themselves
unattractive
huh
yeah
which which which can be a pretty high
percentage actually even if you just
look at i don't know obesity for example
like yeah yeah i mean if you look at if
you look at pictures from
just look at pictures from the
1970s or 1960s like most women are
attractive
most of them are attractive i will say
that the one thing that you can't
overcome is being short as a guy
to be born short yeah it's a it's a it's
a disadvantage i mean
no i mean like look if if a woman keeps
her is at healthy body weight
and you know
grows you know has a nice nice hairstyle
and just dresses nicely and is just you
know somewhat feminine
then
i mean that already puts her in probably
like top i don't know 25
right that's not right like that's not a
huge issue
it depends on where you are like if you
go to like central europe or eastern
europe then no like that's not going to
be at the top but
like honestly the amount of people even
young people who this goes for men too
who just let themselves go already by
the age of like 20 is
pretty
pretty bonkers i mean i i also think
most men can be attractive like i think
most i think most people
could be attractive with like some
moderate
effort and care
yeah yeah like like honestly you know i
mean if you take any guy off the street
um
you know whatever it's like okay get him
get him in the gym and eating well for
like a year to two years
like get him a decent haircut like if
he's wearing like
just bad style like terrible clothes
just like you know swap that yeah it's
like okay like he'll even physically
he'll like already look like pretty
decent and then yeah you know
other things you know confidence humor
all that like there there's there's more
to it but
a lot of people the truth is a lot of
people don't put put very little
appearance
into even trying to be attractive that's
that's the truth like both men and women
like a lot of people just don't even try
and then a lot of times once people are
in relationships they try even less like
they just like whatever like yeah and so
merely trying
you're merely putting in some effort
whether you're a man or a woman
already is um
yeah in this day and age like that's
already
that's already something that's already
something
yeah
yeah that's
i i think he won this argument i'm not
gonna idea
i do i do
i do think about these things a lot i've
thought about them from like a pretty
young age to be honest
i'm new to the madness i actually didn't
realize until recently the way people
treat you different just because you're
a girl
and i i did not realize that until super
recently like mine did not realize that
well because you just think everyone's
treated like that i don't know
what
what specifically do you mean well okay
i'll give you i'll give you an example
right i i do um rap reactions on my
account right so um
my boyfriend he's very like into like
super like um frida frida bang i think
his name is
yeah those guys um i i don't i don't
listen to that that's not i listen to
country and he thought it was really
funny watching me like react to these
videos because i didn't know what they
meant
um it was like a steppa i didn't know
what that meant um i still don't but
he i wanted to get like a
collab with a rapper and get a reaction
and like they'll respond to me but he
has over a million followers on
instagram and like they don't respond to
him
just because i'm a girl you know what
i'm saying just because i'm a girl
yeah yeah
so
there you go this is what i'm talking
about about the world being easier for
you yeah
it might it might sometimes be it might
sometimes be for the wrong reasons but
it's just how it is i just proved your
point but
sorry i think i think i just went over
our time but this is fine it's fine
this was so fun though um thank you so
much for coming on i know you have a
bigger platform than me so i was
actually really excited that you said
yes
no die you're welcome you're welcome
well if people want to check my stuff
out you can follow me at zooby music on
all platforms twitter instagram facebook
youtube
and um
if you go to zoobeemusic.com i've got
all of my music podcasts merch links to
everything on there so you can check
that out